this is going to be on twister the ride
while the people are waiting in line
they'll have to kind of walk up steps
like this
you want to want to come on in here for
a second are we are we rolling we're on
oh yes just another day on the set of
twister
everything's a little twisted here
my god this is fun hang on
this is the first time i've been on this
set
what goes up must come
down oh god i can't even sit here look
at this
spinning house got to go round
talk about your trouble it's a crying
shame
well here we are on the set of twister
uh this is going to be the infamous
spinning house
set we shot the exterior of this
what happens here is uh helen hunt who
plays joe and myself for chasing the big
f5 tornado
i don't want to surprise anybody but all
of a sudden a farm house just falls
right into the road and before we can
stop we go right through it
i think we're going
[Music]
anyway let's keep this tour on the road
let's see here i don't want to break my
neck
what we are trying to do in the movie is
we're trying to put a weather package
almost like we describe it to the
audience like a flight recorder
in the damaged path that means we have
to get to the north the northeast of the
tornado
deploy this thing close enough to the
tornado so that it can get picked up
in the hopes of of gleaning insight and
unlocking some of the mysteries
this movie's going to do for tornadoes i
think what jaws did for sharks
it's going to make people a little
intrepid about it when they see you know
some
wall clouds or some dark clouds it's
coming
it's headed right for us and that's
what's cool about this movie
so much of about tornadoes is almost
surrealistic
i mean they they can do things that defy
the laws of physics
you know they can stick a feather
through you know through through the
side of a car
i mean they can pick things up and carry
them for hundreds of miles
cow god this is a hard way to sit so i'm
going to
move out of here i love stuff like this
i think i'm going to build a house like
this it'd be kind of fun
where's my truck
i think this movie is going to appeal to
all ages
and all situations around the world
weirdly enough tornadoes occur around
the world but they don't
occur with the ferocity or the frequency
that they
uh occur in in the central united states
which kind of makes them a
quintessentially
american phenomena i think there's this
you know
this primordial fascination and of
dealing with the weathers
another cow actually i think that was
the same watch
i knew i shouldn't have had that other
[Music]
drink